third time there are three kinds of
geometric transmission okay where's you
can take a figure or a graph function
region you like and adjust it slightly
so it's still the same recognizable
shape but it's different okay
now you already know that one of them is
translation okay translation is pretty
simple it's just about horizontal or
vertical movement same shape same
dimensions same proportions and you just
sort of shifting it around in fact
shifting is what we call it usually
especially if you've got a periodic
function we call it a phase shift but
what it really is is a translation
across the axis now that's one of them
what other kinds of ways for do things
reflection reflection of man okay so you
can reflect things across any axis you
like or you could reflect across a point
if you want it in the last one is
rotational now the cool thing about this
about seen at these three are actually
there are some related to each other
because for instance you can think of
translation as a pair of reflections you
know that way if you had a letter like
that okay and you had an axis that you
were reflecting across what happened
it'd be something like this right and
then you can reflect it again however
you know maybe the Kois off like that
and every state you have a translation
or you can do a number of lectures to
get a rotation or you can actually mix
and match so anyway those are is it kind
of one to wrap your head around
translations are particularly important
for functions now your lips we learn a
standard form for the equation of the
ellipse last time the lesson before that
what was it standard form
come on it's only one question to say
expert on a squared plus one okay
that was about about ten percent will
coordinate about sixty percent more
volume I think just follow all right now
we will move off there are what kinds of
features can we see about it for
instance this and this being one of
those significance the the and the big
you can thing out a couple of ways
number one you can think about them as
the x and y-intercepts if you take
castle notice is the symmetry okay
probably a better way to think about it
something which is going to be more
general after we translate is that these
are the semi-major and semi-minor axes
it's those lengths right so instead of a
radius because an ellipse doesn't have a
radius you have these kinds of laser
obviously if we switch them around right
now which is this is it wider or is it
taller at the moment its wider because a
is the semi-major one and to attach to X
which is horizontal but we can switch
them around and you get a thin circles
by the way when you switch them around
what else do you have to switch because
it's not just switching these two
they're other features okay so the foci
instead of being on the x axis I got to
be on the y axis somewhere and the
directories will no longer be these two
vertical train lines they're going to be
horizontal trainer so that's all fine
but at the moment everything is centered
on the origin okay so let's just quickly
think through what happens when we
translate it okay how do we normally
translate like say a circle right take
the unit circle its centers also the
origin okay what's the standard form in
terms of the equation of the relation
for a circle without a center of the
origin I think it's by conventions HK I
don't know
okay why did you I should know exactly I
know exaggerate chk it's because I and J
are both to do with your eyes about them
you know what eyes about and J is about
what's a call it's another important
concept it's in comfortable anyway it
doesn't matter if my Center were HK all
my funk is out there rejoiced okay
what would the equation be okay good
good X minus H squared plus y minus K
also squared equals 1 ok great right now
I'm going to do the same business with
the ellipse
okay so up here I want to modify X and
modify line just like I have with the
circle so I'll have X minus H squared
still on a squared ok plus y minus K
squared
still on base but so far so good ok
Center H ok all right now right now I
don't this is not very good what I want
to do is think about the rest of the
features ok so maybe I should have put
it like this
okay what other kinds of features do we
know about the ellipse okay how about
the foci all right where are they when
you're centered on the origin one of the
coordinates what plus or minus AE good
okay and you're on the axis right now if
I've moved over H units where will the
foci be now they also do that good okay
fantastic
what about the directrix or direct
recedes rather okay they're straight
lines the vertical so they're in the
form x equals okay and they they're
normally plus or minus a on Eve okay
just like everything else we've shifted
it over a shoe natal away sir H plus a
on e who's happy hands up hands are
straight there's people with their hands
down I'm interested okay for chance a
chance now if you didn't have your hand
up just now why aren't you happy
okay all right this is zero there but
this should not be a zero you can sort
of get away with it here because it
doesn't matter where this is vertically
it will still be the same line but since
we've moved this up or down this also
needs to move up or down with it
so that should be okay said all right
good